thanks so much for being here
congratulations i heard you had a baby i
had a baby yeah just a couple days ago
i actually did it i had a baby it's
never been done before uh
no uh we had a baby yeah not that bad uh
it was a couple days ago last wednesday
uh
my wife gave birth to a boy which is our
first boy so we were very excited now
but now it's this whole new i actually
it's great that you're on tonight
because
i don't know what i'm doing and you
actually have
a little girl and a little boy yeah and
so you can help me out i don't know what
i'm doing either but
really really are they i mean because
you don't have to have a license
you don't have to have a license i
clearly need a license yeah one of the
things they've warned me about
is you've got to make sure that our
daughter who doesn't get jealous
yeah so they told us all these things
like give her presents
and say it's from the baby boy who just
showed up
but i think she knows something's up
she's like how did he
he doesn't buy any money yeah where did
he go and he has a credit card
yeah exactly there's all these weird
things like that that you think how is
that going did you have to worry about
that yeah i think we did that too and my
daughter is pretty savvy she's like
yeah daddy told me that it came from
deacon but i know he went and bought it
himself
right she's very savvy but there is like
a big difference between boys and girls
it's just
they're so different like even tonight i
was just i was leaving the hotel and my
son
he has just a really quick temper and i
said i have to go to work and he went
and he threw his truck at me and ava
goes now deacon
she goes mommy has to go to work so she
can make money so she can pay the bills
so you can keep your pillow in your
blanket
that's incredible
that's scary she's incredible she did it
all while she was coloring
yeah yeah that's why she's got attitude
also
i can do this in color at the same time
she didn't look up
that is amazing the other thing they
they told us about was i mean so far
our boy is so mellow he's just a baby
but our daughter was so kind of intense
and the baby's like
goo goo you know like he's gonna be like
here
he's chilling here he's doing a good job
but no two is a whole new
thing and one thing the pediatrician
told us to do is when you talk to
uh your daughter come up with all these
things that she can so that she doesn't
get jealous say
you've got pants in your you've got
pockets on your pants
little uh beckett doesn't have that
because she's too little
like and i thought it just sounds like
we're taunting the new baby
you can walk but he can't cause he's too
little like
it just seems like a weird there's
people overthink it maybe you know
somebody told me like i'm a director of
a school or something make sure you
complain about the baby to the older
child like
he's crying it's really hurting my ears
i really don't like it with a baby
like and i thought that was kind of
weird and somewhat evil
yeah i really hate your brother
maybe you and i should just go hate you
yeah exactly that's a good idea
you you seem like you'd be a a terrific
mom you're very together you're very
well organized person
i've read is that true is that fair to
say you know i don't think i am and then
i have these moments where i'm just you
know
the over the summer we went to visit
ryan's parents in um delaware and they
just got in this new house and
uh everybody was kind of sleeping and i
was jet lagged so i woke up early and i
tiptoed nestor and i discovered she had
one of those
label makers and i started labeling her
house
and i was like and then she came down
she's like what are you doing i said
oh it's just labeling your china in your
napkin drawer and she's just
like what what are you doing it was just
odd that is like no one that's not
that's a strange i mean i can see that
some people were relaxed
relaxed that way but you just you know
it's weird to do it in someone else's
home probably you know
or your mother-in-law yeah you showed up
early and you made a label for me that
said host
and you put it i'm gonna put that right
on your head you know it makes things
very clear
yeah clear and someone knows their place
you stay over there you stay there your
host i am guest
we work this out now i want to talk
about this movie i saw this movie a
couple of days ago and it it blew me
away
and you had a baby you actually saw this
this is yeah this is one of the
last things i did before the baby was
born that's great i mean i was sitting
there with
my wife was happy about that yeah no
actually
she came with me i'll just be in labor
no she came with me she wasn't in labor
yet we came we saw the movie
and then uh that did it she's like
wow it was that good the baby was like
there must be more films like this in
the world
uh no uh it it really is an
extraordinary film
and uh it's it's a it's a great love
story
johnny cash june carter cash this is a
an amazing story
and what i didn't realize is you're you
sing in this movie but when you
when you got the role you didn't know
that you were really going to be singing
is that right
i was a little bit uh hoodwinked there
they told me i had this job and i was
gonna do the acting part and play june
carter and
um and then about two weeks after i
signed all the contracts they
they the director called me up and he
said i want you to come to my house and
i came to his house and he said sing a
little something for me
i was like why he said well oh cause i'm
gonna have you record all her tracks
and i just freaked out because i've
never sung before professionally and
moreover than that it was just i have
stage fright terrible stage right i
sweat
my knees sweat my ears sweat when i see
more than 20 people
it makes me very nervous right right
don't look over there
there's no one there it's a laugh track
get out
um but you know what's funny
is i mean i'm not just saying this you
you
you're you you're great you really you
do a fantastic job you're a great singer
and so it's a little hard for me to
believe that you hadn't done it before
how did you get to that point where you
could sing like this
um well we practiced we did six months
of voice lessons
um and then we uh we recorded an album
over six months but that was that was a
long time to rehearse for a movie i mean
we usually rehearse for a week
and um i got to learn how to sing
basically this this man roger love
taught me how to sing
and now you're a little uncomfortable
because people i understand are coming
up to you and saying you're a great
singer and you feel like oh no i'm not
i'm you know
yeah well this morning i was on um good
morning america and um
i was in the elevator with garth brooks
and there's like 12 people in the
elevator and
there was garth brooks and he's this big
country music star and someone across
the elevator across garth brooks to me
goes
rhys i heard you're a really good singer
in the movie
you're so good oh my gosh i didn't know
you could sing and i keep looking at him
going
no i can't handle it yeah yeah i was so
embarrassed
she's like oh you tried to sing in this
movie i was like yeah it just feels like
i don't want garth brooks in the
elevator when this has happened then
she's like no you're the best singer in
the elevator
not good not good